you see I got this shirt tucked in right
that means no I don't know what got your
shirt tucked in right that means you
learn you know this are you going when
you go on a job if you want me to start
tucked in cuz you mean business right
[Music]
hello I am Chad Johnson I am here with
my good friend and Hall of Fame receiver
Terrell Owens and up-and-coming draft
prospect one of the best receivers in
the nation
Riley Ridley
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you feel like your best asset is
as a receiver
right now I'm physically okay I'm
physical more physical to any receive
we're going into the draft I'm more
physical to any DB so that's something
that you don't have to work on so now
you got a word about working on the
finesse part of the game so you got T
here muscle right physical physical get
to you and then you have my skill set
was completely opposite don't touch me
good I'd like to do it like I like to
get jiggy at the line man let's ride
with you don't and I need all this space
my coach said wonder he said this to me
because he knew I like basketball right
and this is what clicked for me he said
you have to treat the defensive back
like you're playing one-on-one you
playing one-on-one and you're trying to
get by me what are you gonna do you
gotta make me move right same thing with
every route pretty much because I'm
trying to score a book I what I'm trying
to get at I'm here he'll give you to
stuff some gear right into this
okay so Miller I'm going okay initially
when you came up the ball boom you kind
of got wide a little bit right try to
stay a little bit even so I like what
you put my ball here then kind of get
into him invited you can invite it but
you want him when you hear you want to
accept you want to show that
acceleration like you about to go DB
then you stopped my problem was when I
used to get it going to my brakes I just
say yeah just have these flappers out
here and then I had my coach over my
head you be a drummer boy you know me be
a drummer boy then when I did when I did
hit the transition it's ending out of my
brakes quick right we're trying to get
you to become a Salesman before you act
with a Salesman I do a dig route based
on an offer of a comeback stem I call
the cinema center due to the Gatorade
I'm gonna send him to the Gatorade so
just say come on come on just say the
ball is in there right the ball is in
there and I got a dead ground so this is
what I'm gonna do boom boom I'm again
right here uh-huh
poof I'm gonna send him to the Gatorade
no doubt all of this is right here don't
go soon as you know that way he'd go and
very seldom on deep balls do you just
blow by a dude that ain't happened yeah
Betty happen unless you just beat
somebody off the line you just yeah
exactly yeah I mean you got to be
goddamn Tyree killer some brandy brandy
here's a few yeah Randy you see the
mailbox it's really over that not not
everybody like that he's freakish freak
it's freakishly fast right y'all mean to
the point he started coming off flying
he already 5 yards away even through his
Hannah it's a bunch of receives an NFL
right starting two teams there's number
one on every team right what's the
difference in each number one and the
rest receives on the team if something
about that dude that makes them special
there's something about Odell that makes
him different than the rest of the
Giants receivers learn something about
AV that makes them special
something about Julio right you got to
going wherever you go when you get there
they got to be something about really
that makes them special
who's that that separates them from
everybody else load up when it's the way
you work whether it's your hand let's
defeat whether it's your routes mmm
where's you being consistent there guys
maybe something one ain't gonna be a
bunch of things it's good thing about
four that makes them great it's a
million boxes yeah you're not gonna hit
me let me hit you whenever I want so as
a receiver you find whatever that niche
about you that makes you special
It's A Wrap I got a brother in the NFL
but to be able to go through this on
your own you know I'm saying to have
great people around you and willing to
help you miss amazing and Cal really if
you see this I will lock you up know you
even a lot nobody nobody